RONALD SMITH: Well, we're getting into weather,
and so I'm going to be paying a
bit more attention to what's
going on around us.
And this the--
a weather map from the
00Z soundings.
In other words, the
soundings--
the balloons that were launched
yesterday evening at
8:00 PM here would be
00Z Greenwich time.
And each of these little
clusters of data represents a
balloon that was launched.
And this is the 500 millibar
map, so when data is analyzed
above the Earth's surface, it's
normally done on constant
pressure surfaces.
It's not exactly constant
altitude, but it's more or
less a flat, horizontal
surface.
And what's contoured in
black is actually
the altitude itself.
So that constant pressure
surface is
a little bit rolling.
But the thing to understand is
that the level of constant
altitude on a pressure surface
is very much analogous to an
isobaric curve on
a level surface.
So you can think of
these as isobars,
these heavy black lines.
The temperture-- lines of
constant temperature, the
isotherms, are in the
dashed blue lines.
But the data from which
it is all derived are
these little clusters.
So there is the--
to the right of the symbol is
the altitude of the 500
millibar surface with
one zero left off.
So at that station, the 500
millibar surface is 5,870
meters above sea level.
The temperature is 27
Celsius, and the dew
point is minus 11 Celsius.
So each of those balloons, as
they cross that surface, you
have the data there.
And then the contours are
laid on by the computer.
The winds are given too in a
little wind barb using the
convention of a short feather
being five knots, a long
feather being 10 knots, and
a thick feather like
that being 50 knots.
So we're talking about
geostrophic balance.
And I showed you a diagram like
this last time, but I
wanted to bring it up
to date by showing
you the current one.
So this is the soundings
again from last night.
It shows this rather interesting
little circular
pattern over the East Coast.
And if you look at
these values--
560, 550, I guess, 549--
so this is a low-pressure
center, so this would be
called a cyclone.
It's not at the Earth's
surface, necessarily.
It's about five kilometers
up in the atmosphere.
But that would be a cyclone.
So higher pressure around it,
lower pressure in the center.
And just like we derived
theoretically, the winds go
counterclockwise around that
because we're in the Northern
Hemisphere.
And notice how well the winds
parallel the isobars.
And so these conclusions have
followed from the geostrophic
balance assumption.
And the closer the isobars are
together, the stronger the
wind will be.
Here's another system over the
West Coast, a strong jet
stream coming up here.
Winds reaching to about 65 knots
where the isobars are
closer together, and then where
the isobars are further
apart, the winds are
considerably weaker.
So those general rules about
geostrophic balance are seen
to hold on this kind
of a diagram.
Are there any questions on this
one before I go back to
the main lecture?
So these maps are easy to find,
and I encourage you to
check in with them from time to
time see what's going on.
Let me just get rid of this and
go back to where we were.
Yeah, let me just go
back for a second.
So we're in the geostrophic
discussion.
I showed you these little
bullet points about
geostrophic force balance.
These formulas, we
went through.
This is the map that I showed
you last Friday.
This was from that moment.
And of course, things
have changed a bit
between now and then.
It may be that that same trough
is the one that's slid
east and become a cut-off
cyclone the way we saw, or
maybe some other thing happened
between the two dates.
But I suspect it's just that
that slid over to the east and
filled out to form a full, round
cyclone the way we saw.
I think I ended with this one,
which was just an example of
an isobaric map at the
surface of the Earth.
These values are sea-level
pressure, so wherever the
pressure was measured, it was
reduced to a common altitude,
sea level, and then the contours
were laid on it.
So you can use this
to analyze then.
And here we had an anticyclone
and a cyclone.
There are no winds given on
this, but now, knowing the
geostrophic law, we can say
quite a bit about this.
The only problem is that this
is down close to the surface
of the Earth, and in some cases
even below the surface
of the Earth.
This is kind of a fictitious--
there's no--
these mountains are a kilometer
or two above sea
level, so producing a sea-level
map is a little bit
odd for that.
But that's OK.
We can still interpret it.
But the other problem is that
when you're right down near
the surface of the Earth, there
is some friction added
to the winds as well, and that
will break the geostrophic
constraint maybe not too badly,
but it'll break it a
little bit.
What tends to happen when you're
near the surface is
that the winds, instead of
blowing right along the
isobars, tend to rotate
in a little bit.
So they're mostly going along
the isobars, but they're
crossing it a little bit from
high pressure to low.
So the winds tend to rotate
a little bit like that.
That subject is called
the Ekman layer.
The Ekman layer is a description
of how those winds
turn in the boundary layer.
And when you're analyzing
your pilot
balloon data in the lab--
in lab number two, you might
find some hint of that, some
rotation of the wind in the
boundary layer due to that
breaking of the geostrophic
law due to friction.
So keep-- you may not see it or
you may see it, but keep an
eye open for it in that data
that you're analyzing from the
pilot balloon launch.
So what more can I say?
Well, we're going to be talking
about mid-latitude
cyclones probably next time, and
this is an example where
in addition to sketching in
the isobars, they've also
drawn in their interpretation
of where the cold fronts and
the warm fronts are on
this particular day.
But that's more of an
interpretive thing.
The isobars are just
cut and dry.
If you know the pressure data,
you can contour those in.
If you expand out to look
at most of the Northern
Hemisphere, you can see that at
any given time, there are
lots of highs and lows, cyclones
and anticyclones.
And again, no wind is given on
this, but you can get a pretty
good idea of what the wind is.
Each one of these lows has the
wind going around this way.
Each one of the highs has the
wind going around that way.
And the speed of the wind
is related to the
packing of the isobars.
So the mid-latitude and
high-latitude atmosphere is
just loaded with these eddies.
And one of their jobs is to pump
heat northward to balance
the heat budget of the high
latitudes and low latitudes,
which I spoke about last time.
If you go to the Southern
Hemisphere-- here's
Australia--
of course, now everything is
backwards, because the
Coriolis force is reversed in
the Southern Hemisphere.
It acts to the left of
the motion vector.
And so those relationships that
we derived have to be
reversed also.
So here is a low-pressure
center.
We would call it a cyclone.
And the sea-level pressure is
given there, 968 millibars,
976, getting higher
as you go away.
And they've indicated the arrow
here indicating the
direction of circulation, and
indeed, it is clockwise.
So the circulation around this
cyclone is opposite to what it
would be if we were in the
Northern Hemisphere, because
the-- well, the Coriolis force
has a reversed sign.
And again, if you look at a
larger map with the Southern
Hemisphere, here's Antarctica,
Australia, Cape Horn, Cape of
Good Hope, filled with
highs and lows.
And again, all the circulations
are the opposite
to what they would be in the
Northern Hemisphere.
So a few things.
To finish up the discussion, I
wanted to mention these four
items and also see if you
have any questions.
So try to think up some
questions before we finish
this subject.
First of all, geostrophic
adjustment.
It's fine to claim that the
Earth's atmosphere is in
geostrophic balance
most of the time.
But I think an even more
fundamental question is how
does it come to be in
geostrophic balance?
And that process is called
geostrophic adjustment.
And one way to imagine it--
but you can do these
calculations on your own-- is
to imagine you've got some
isobars drawn on a map.
In this case, they've been drawn
east-west, and they've
been labeled with pressure.
And let's assume at the
beginning moment that you've
got a parcel of air sitting
there not moving.
Well, you know that's not in
geostrophic balance, because
it's in a region that has
a pressure gradient.
So it's going to have a pressure
gradient force.
But if it's not moving, it can't
have a Coriolis force,
so those two forces cannot
possibly be in balance.
So here's your parcel
not moving.
I release it, and it's going
to immediately feel the
pressure gradient force pushing
it towards the north.
It's going to start to
accelerate in that direction.
So as the minutes and hours tick
by, starting with zero
speed, it's going to have then
maybe one meter per second,
two meters per second, three
meters per second.
But now, as it picks up speed,
it's going to start to feel a
Coriolis force, small at first,
because remember, the
Coriolis force is proportional
to the wind speed.
So after some time, it may have
moved to here, and it
will have developed a little
bit of Coriolis force, and
it'll start to turn.
The Coriolis force is
a deflecting force.
It'll start to turn.
Throughout all this time,
however, because I've drawn
these isobars equally spaced,
the pressure gradient force on
that parcel will remain
the same.
So it's always being pushed to
the north by the pressure
gradient force, but as it moves
and accelerates, it
turns and accelerates and
eventually ends up moving east
with a speed that will give it
an equal and opposite Coriolis
force and pressure gradient.
So that will-- that process of
geostrophic adjustment usually
takes about 12 hours
in the atmosphere.
Parcels could be disturbed
by getting caught up in a
thunderstorm.
They could be disturbed by
running against a mountain
range and being deflected,
running against a building and
getting deflected.
But then, as the hours pass, it
naturally tends to want to
return to a state of geostrophic
balance.
It's a natural tendency in the
atmosphere for the wind to try
to readjust itself to
geostrophic balance.
What you might do is leave a
couple of inches in your notes
and either redraw the isobars
with some other orientation
and repeat the experiment.
Or to be even more confusing,
perhaps, start that parcel off
in some arbitrary direction and
imagine what's going to
happen to it.
If you start it off with some
speed, it's going to have a
Coriolis force, but it's going
to be in the wrong direction
for geostrophic balance.
Then follow that parcel just
with your little sketch, and
see how it is that it loops
around and eventually
reestablishes geostrophic
balance.
It'll always get there.
No matter what direction you
start that parcel, it'll loop
around in such a way that it'll
eventually end up in
geostrophic balance.
So do some practice on that.
Any questions on this process
of geostrophic adjustment?
The same thing happens in
the oceans, by the way.
The Coriolis force acts on
ocean currents, and ocean
currents are even in a more
rigorous state of geostrophic
balance than is the
atmosphere.
So these same principles we're
learning now apply to ocean
currents as well.
It's ironic that this Coriolis
force, which is so small that
we don't notice it in our
everyday lives, yet has this
dominant force on
a larger scale.
Yes.
STUDENT: What do the arrows
going up and down and then
right by "air flow"-- it's
starting to curve-- what do
those represent?
PROFESSOR: These?
STUDENT: No, on the Coriolis--
PROFESSOR: So this one is the pressure
gradient force.
And I don't know why
they've changed it.
The artist wasn't
careful here.
But this pressure gradient--
because these isobars are
equally spaced, four millibars
and four millibars, this
pressure gradient force should
be the same always
in this diagram.
And this one is the
Coriolis force.
Notice it's always at right
angles to the motion vector.
So when the parcel's moving in
that direction, the Coriolis
force is like that.
When the parcel's moving in that
direction, the Coriolis
force is like this.
So you need to adhere to that
when you're constructing these
little cartoons, to be sure
you're always drawing the
Coriolis force perpendicular
to the motion vector.
And in this simple case, the
pressure gradient force will
always be towards the north,
because the pressure decreases
towards the north.
Good question.
Now, this reversal in the two
hemispheres, I think it's
pretty clear why it happens.
I wanted to show you these
two satellite images of
hurricanes.
This one, you know
where it is.
There's Florida and Cuba.
So this is in the Northern
Hemisphere.
Now, to be honest with you,
looking at the top of a
hurricane with a satellite, even
if it's in motion, it's a
little bit hard to tell what
direction the winds are going
near the surface.
Because what you're seeing are
these high anvil clouds that
are spreading out near the
tropopause and covering most
everything, and these clouds
tend to rotate maybe in this
direction near the center, but
then further out, they're
rotating in the opposite
direction.
So it's a little bit
complicated, so I'm not going
to try to convince you that you
can determine which way
that thing is spinning from
that still picture.
I'm not going to claim that.
But nevertheless, I will ask
you to notice that, in
general, these two photographs
are opposite.
Right?
The spiral bands go off outwards
and to the right
here, outwards to
the left below.
But here, outwards to the left
and outwards to the right.
So that general spiral pattern
is reversed in the two
hemispheres.
That, you can see
for yourself.
And were you to look, were you
to have some data about the
winds near the surface of the
Earth, you would find the
winds moving very rapidly in a
counterclockwise direction
here and in the clockwise
direction there.
So they really are reversed
in the two hemispheres.
We'll talk about hurricanes
probably starting next time or
the time after that, and
we'll struggle with
this a little bit.
For example, you might ask
what would happen if a
hurricane tried to cross
the Equator?
Well, would it have to switch
its direction of rotation?
The answer is probably
so, but it's never
been observed to happen.
A hurricane has never
successfully crossed the Equator.
It would be in a foreign
country, right?
In other words, it's constructed
itself to be
appropriate with the sense of
the Coriolis force in the
Northern Hemisphere.
If you tried to push that into
the Southern Hemisphere, it
would have to really fall apart
and then rebuild itself
in the opposite direction.
That's never been
seen to happen.
We'll talk more about things
like that when we get into
hurricanes.
Let's see.
I was going to talk about
toilet bowl mythology.
So how many of you heard
the legend of the
toilet bowls in Australia?
So the legend is that if you
flush the toilet bowl in
Australia, the water will swirl
down in the opposite
direction to that in the
Northern Hemisphere.
Well, I don't think
that's true.
I have tested it on occasion,
but the problem is that the
Coriolis force acting on a small
scale is a rather small
force, and other things
may dominate.
And here's what would dominate
in the case of a toilet bowl
or any small body of water.
If you take a tank of water and
fill it and you're even
the least little bit careless,
you're going to be pouring the
water into that off-center a
little bit, and you're going
to be giving it a little bit of
swirl to begin with, just
from the way you filled
the basin.
Now, when you pull a plug at
the bottom and that water
begins to move towards the
center and then drain out, the
conservation of angular momentum
will amplify whatever
little swirl is in there.
And so it'll end up swirling
faster and faster as you draw
the water out, but in the
direction of the swirl that
you gave it initially.
And in almost every case, that's
going to dominate over
that weak Coriolis force acting
on such a small scale.
Now, this idea was tested some
years ago up at the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution.
They took a large tank of water,
about this size and
about my height, and they filled
it ever so carefully to
avoid swirl.
But that wasn't good enough.
They then lowered into it a
kind of a honeycomb set of
dividers that, once it was down
in there, would stop any
swirl that was existing.
They then pulled it out
carefully and waited for
several days to get rid of any
other remaining swirl.
Then they pulled the plug in
the middle at the bottom.
And it took several hours to see
it, but gradually, there
was a swirl observed, and it was
due to the Coriolis force.
In other words, as the air
moved-- as the water moved in
towards the center, the
deflecting force took the
water that way, this one took
the water that way, acting to
the right of that motion towards
the center, and lo and
behold, they did get
a cyclonic swirl--
that is, a counterclockwise
swirl--
due to the Coriolis force.
But I tell that story because
of the extent you have to go
to to get that effect
to dominate
over the initial swirl.
So don't expect to find that
as you switch hemispheres.
You'd have to do the
experiment much more carefully.
Now, that leads me
to this story.
So years ago, I was in Kenya,
driving north to south across
the Equator.
And there's a number of souvenir
shops at the Equator,
with signs like this out front
or other signs on the building
that say, get your Equator
souvenirs here.
And we stopped at one of
them, and the owner
came running out.
And before he allowed us to go
in the store, he wanted to
prove to us that his store was
the one that was really right
on the Equator, and all those
others we could see up and
down the road were fake.
And so he did a little
experiment for us.
You can see that.
But he's got a little red
plastic dish with a hole in
the bottom, and then a blue
bucket beneath that.
Now, here I am watching him like
a hawk, because this is
my subject, right?
So this is a little toward the
end of the experiment.
First, he walked a few tens of
yards north of the sign, and
he put his finger under the
hole on the red dish and
poured the water into it, put
a few matchsticks on the top
so we could see the swirl that
was developed, and when he
took his finger off the hole,
the water rushed out the hole.
And indeed, it did swirl down.
He then walked several meters
south of his sign and repeated
the experiment, and indeed,
it swirled down in
the opposite direction.
He then went right under the
sign-- and that's the picture
you see there--
and I noticed that
his protocol was
a little bit different.
He poured in most of the water
and then waited for a few
seconds, then poured in the
rest, then took his finger off
the hole, and the water ran
right down without a swirl.
He did a very nice job
on this experiment.
And of course, the point was
that the Coriolis force has
one sign to the north of the
Equator, another sign to the
south of the Equator, and
there's no Coriolis force
right at the Equator.
However, I didn't have the heart
to tell him that he had
it backwards.
Did you notice the way
I moved my hand?
When he was north of the
Equator, he had it swirling
down this way, and when he was
south of the Equator, he had
it swirling down this way, just
the opposite of what the
Coriolis force would do.
Nevertheless, we were so pleased
we went in and bought
lots of souvenirs.
So he won the day.
But it makes my point that there
is this odd situation
that the Coriolis force is such
a small force that you
won't see it on small-scale
experiments like this, because
other effects-- for example,
this initial swirl--
is going to dominate over that
small Coriolis force.
But on the large scale,
it'll dominate.
Questions on the
Coriolis force?
We have a few minutes where
I'd be happy to take your
questions about the
Coriolis force.
Anything?
Well, we're going
to switch gears.
We're going to start talking
about storm types.
And I want to start out by
showing you a picture that
Jude gave me, our videographer
in the back of the room here.
In New Haven a few days ago,
he took this nice shot of a
mammatus cloud.
We're going to be talking about
thunderstorms in just a
minute in this course.
By the way, if anybody else has
nice pictures of clouds
that you've taken yourself,
don't hesitate to
send them to me.
I may even put them up
on our class website.
But that's a real nice one.
Remember, this kind of cloud
occurs underneath a
thunderstorm anvil.
So cumulonimbus builds up, hits
the tropopause, the anvil
spreads out, and then underneath
that, you get these
falling pendants of cloud that
take on this appearance of a
mammatus cloud.
But now we're going to talk
about storms, and we're going
to stay on this subject
for a day or two.
It's a huge subject.
Your book is really good and
voluminous on this subject,
and I assume you've
already read a
number of these chapters.
I hope you're doing that.
But the tough thing is
to define a storm.
The word "storm," what the
heck does it mean?
I honestly--
I didn't look it up in the
dictionary, but my
definition would be--
a meteorologist's definition
would be that it represents
some kind of a local energy
transformation, a
transformation from one kind of
an energy to another, for
example, maybe potential energy
to wind energy, to
kinetic energy of motion,
or something like that.
It's not an object.
It's not a physical object.
In fact, the air that's involved
in a storm might even
be flowing through it.
The air that's in a storm today,
that storm may still
exist tomorrow, but it may have
a whole different set of
air that comprises it.
So it's not a physical object.
It's a pattern of winds, of
vertical motions of clouds, of
precipitation in the air.
This is what makes it so
fascinating to study, because
its a little bit--
all these things are a little
bit mysterious.
They're not exactly objects.
They're patterns of complicated
fluid motion
within a larger atmosphere.
Now, they may be dangerous,
but I don't want to
define it that way.
I don't want to define a storm
as something that necessarily
causes damage or takes
human lives.
In fact, in some cases, it may
be the only thing that brings
needed rain.
Most types of storms produce
precipitation in some way, and
in many climates, that
is the rain producer.
So storms should not be
considered all bad.
Typically, they are short-lived,
however.
I can't think of any examples
where a storm of any of the
types I will define in just a
moment exists more than three
or four days.
Now, there may be other storms
nearby that grow as that one
decays, but if you try to track
an individual storm,
like a hurricane, normally, a
few days, and they've gone
through their life cycle.
Some of these have natural life
cycles, and some of them
just die for other reasons.
And I've indicated that we're
interested in climate in this
course as well.
But you can't define
climate without
understanding storms either.
Because the storms that occur
in a particular location are
part of the definition
of the climate.
For example, here in New Haven,
we get a certain amount
of rain in the summertime, and
almost all of that comes from
thunderstorms. We get rain in
the wintertime, and almost all
of that comes from mid-latitude
frontal cyclones.
So without knowing something
about storm types, you really
don't have much to say
about climate either.
They really are part of the
recurring patterns of
temperature and precipitation
and wind that occur in any
particular location.
Any questions about what I
mean by a storm, then?
I'm using it very broadly.
Now, with those definitions, I
want to break them down into
two broad categories, convective
and frontal.
And convective clouds--
convective storms are those
that are driven by latent
heat release.
We're going to talk about two
or three different kinds of
convective storms, but they all
share the property that
the energy that drives them is
the heat that's released when
water vapor condenses to
form liquid or ice.
And because they depend on
latent heat release, you need
to have a lot of water vapor to
begin with in the air, and
that means these are going to
be warm-season storms--
warm air can hold more
water vapor--
or storms that occur in the
tropics, where you have lots
of water vapor all the time.
But anyway, they're warm storms.
You're not going to
get thunderstorms in--
very rarely would you get
a thunderstorm in high
latitudes, up in the arctic,
for example.
It's not unheard of, but
it's quite rare.
And when you do get it, it's
only because there's been a
big push of warm air temporarily
up into the high
latitudes that has allowed a
thunderstorm to occur there.
A frontal storm, the other broad
category, their energy
source is the horizontal
gradient in temperature.
If I have cold air next to warm
air, that represents a
potential source of energy
because the warm air would
like to rise, and the cold
air would like to sink.
So holding them side by side
is only a temporary thing.
When I release it in some way,
motion is going to begin to
occur, and in some cases,
that'll develop
into a frontal storm.
I say cold season because,
remember, due to the tilt of
the Earth, it's in the
wintertime in mid-latitudes
when you've got the big
differential heating.
The pole is getting no sunlight,
the Equator is
getting a lot, and so it's in
the cold season of each year
for the respective hemispheres
that you get the strong
temperature differences,
which will then allow
frontal storms to form.
Now, this is easy to remember,
because the definition of a
front itself is a region of
strong temperature gradient.
So it's easy to remember what
is the energy source for a
frontal storm.
So first, we're going to talk
about convective storms. And
I'm just going to talk
about three.
Airmass thunderstorms, severe
thunderstorms, your book does
a good job on these.
I'm not going to say much about
the different types of
severe thunderstorms, but there
are subcategories within
the general domain of severe
thunderstorms. And then
hurricanes fall into that
category as well.
So what I'm saying is that all
of these storms are driven by
the energy from latent
heat release.
And remember, that number is
about 2 and 1/2 million joules
per kilogram of water vapor.
So for every kilogram of water
vapor that you condense, you
get 2 and 1/2 million joules
of energy added to the
atmosphere in the
form of heat.
But then that may make that air
rise, and that'll get the
whole storm going.
So it all goes back to this
rather large latent heat
that's present when water
vapor condenses.
So the first and the most benign
of these is the airmass
thunderstorm.
It's called an airmass
thunderstorm because basically
there's a property of the
atmosphere that would allow
them to form.
And so when we say that a warm,
tropical air mass has
moved into New England with the
properties of being warm,
not very stable, and not very
strongly sheared, then
thunderstorms can occur.
So we've kind of included here
the fact that it's the nature
of the air mass that is going
to control whether or not
these thunderstorms occur.
And that's why they're called
airmass thunderstorms.
So they go through
a life cycle.
They start as a fair-weather
cumulus cloud, but there is
enough water vapor in the
atmosphere so that as the air
begins to rise, the latent heat
addition is sufficient to
keep that air moving upwards.
It'll keep going, under many
circumstances, all the way
until it reaches
the tropopause.
It'll flatten out at the
tropopause, maybe overshoot it
a little bit, but generally
flatten out.
And about the time it gets
there, it'll start to rain
heavily out the bottom.
The process by which the
raindrops are made is almost
always the ice phase mechanism
in these clouds.
Remember, it may be very warm
at the surface-- after all,
this is a summertime
phenomenon--
but nevertheless, because it
gets colder as you go up-- and
here's the zero degrees
Celsius line--
once that cloud gets above the
zero degrees Celsius line,
you've got supercooled water
that'll then start the ice
phase process going to generate
at first snowflakes.
Then they'll melt as they fall,
and they'll fall as rain
out the bottom.
There may be some lightning
coming out of those clouds.
If they are moving rapidly
across the landscape, they
will just give you a brief
shower, which won't be too
much of a problem.
If they happen to be stationary,
even though they
may only last for an hour, if
they're stationary, they might
cause some local flooding.
So whether they cause flooding
depends not only on the rain
rate from these systems but how
fast they're moving across
the landscape, whether they're
distributing that
rain as they move.
There might also be some-- of
course, the lightning can
cause damage.
You could be struck by
lightning, or it
could cause a fire.
But normally, these are
not so damaging.
In fact, they bring us most of
the summertime rainfall that
we count on in New Haven and
most of the rest of the world.
In the warm season or the warm
climate zones, this is the
primary rain producer.
So it's definitely
a positive thing.
Questions on airmass
thunderstorms?
I'll show you the distribution
of these in just a minute.
But first I want to start
talking about the severe
thunderstorms. Now, severe
thunderstorms require some of
the same ingredients.
You need to have a warm, moist
atmosphere, no strong
inversions, because you've got
to get the air moving upwards.
But the additional element
determining that you will get
a severe thunderstorm instead
of just an airmass
thunderstorm is wind shear
in the troposphere.
And here they've drawn up
on the right axis--
the artist has drawn in a sense
of that, some low-level
southeasterlies, weak
southeasterlies near the
surface of the Earth, turning
to a jet stream
from the west aloft.
That's the kind of shear I'm
talking about, shear across
the whole tropopause.
So now, instead of getting
this-- instead of getting this
thunderstorm building up and
retaining a kind of symmetry,
instead, as it builds up, it
gets tipped over by the shear.
And that changes everything.
Let me go back.
I forgot to mention something
which is needed now in this
argument, so let me go back for
a moment and point out to
the fact that the air that is
rising is generally converging
into this storm until
the rain begins.
Sorry.
I forgot to mention this.
This is important.
Once the rain begins, the rain
falls below cloud base into
air that has a relative humidity
less than 100%, and
some fraction of the raindrop
water mass is going to
evaporate before those raindrops
hit the surface.
That evaporation causes some
cooling in this area.
And once that is well
established, the cooling by
evaporation of raindrops, that
cool air begins to fall to the
surface and spread out.
When it does that, it shuts
off the inflow.
Here we needed inflow to
keep that cloud going.
Once the downburst begins, once
the cool air begins to
flow down and out, the supply of
warm air rising is cut off,
and this storm dies.
And normally, that whole
sequence takes between an hour
and two hours, and
then it's gone.
There may be other thunderstorms
popping up in
the vicinity, but this one has
a very short lifetime,
typically less than two hours.
And it kills itself off.
It's a form of suicide, where
the rain that falls out the
bottom partially evaporates,
causes cool air, which rushes
down to the surface, spreads
out, and cuts off the inflow
to that storm.
You will feel that.
If you are a few miles away
from this storm, you might
hear the thunder coming
from the lightning.
And then several minutes later,
there may be a cool
gust of wind that comes to you
from the direction of that
thunderstorm.
That's this cool air
falling out of the
bottom of the cloud.
So watch for that, because if
you're aware, you can tell the
outflows coming from each of
these storms as it progresses
through the afternoon
or the evening.
You'll feel these outflows
reaching you.
Now, what's different about a
severe thunderstorm is that
because it's tipped over and
made more complicated, the
inflow continues on one side of
the storm, while the rain
and the outflow is on the
other side of the storm.
They don't cancel each other.
Because it's sheared in this
way, you get air coming in
from the back that gets caught
up in the rain, brought down
to the surface to form the cool
air and the gust front.
And then out ahead of the gust
front comes the warm air,
which is the fuel for the
thunderstorm, that'll rise up
in this way and spread out
to the right and a
little bit to the left.
So the downdraft caused by
evaporation and the updraft,
which is generating the cloud,
do not-- they're not in the
same place, so they don't
cancel each other.
So this can be a long-lived
storm.
This can exist for many hours,
just trucking across the
landscape, sucking up air from
one side, spitting it out the
back along with rain, and
continuing to kind of move
along like that until conditions
change, until it
encounters air that's too dry
or whatever might change,
might eventually
kill the storm.
But it could even
last overnight.
In other words, it could start
this afternoon, and the same
storm could exist through the
night-- in some cases, even
into the next day--
because it doesn't have a way to
naturally kill itself off.
Also, these are much
more severe.
They are broader in extent.
The updrafts are quite
a bit stronger.
Instead of being two or three
or four meters per second
updraft, they could be 10 or
even 15 meters per second
updraft speed.
And this gives rise to a whole
set of new dangers that come
along with this storm.
Here's a picture of one.
The updraft is back in here,
coming right up through there.
And there's the rain
back in the rear.
The anvil-- you can't see the
top of it, but the anvil is up
here somewhere.
There's one from a distance.
We can't see much.
I think this is where the air
is coming up, on this side.
The rain is back here.
There's the anvil
spreading out.
Yes.
STUDENT: What drives what
direction the storm moves?
PROFESSOR: So it's going to move by the
direction of the winds in the
middle of the troposphere.
Typically, the winds around 500
millibars will determine
how that storm moves.
That's a good question.
So normally, from west to east,
but it'll depend on the
local conditions.
Could be in some other direction
if the regional
winds are from a different
direction.
Here's a picture from space
showing the anvil clouds
popping up on this side.
So this list is probably not
inclusive, but I want to
mention at least these things.
What damage do you get from
severe thunderstorms?
Well, heavy rain and flooding.
The rain rates can
be very high.
And again, if they're moving--
if the storm's moving slowly,
that's the most dangerous
situation, because it'll put a
lot of water into
each watershed.
Because the updraft speeds are
so large and there's a lot of
supercooled water above the zero
degrees Celsius line, you
can develop riming, which will
then grow and grow and grow,
and that hailstone can be
suspended for maybe 15 or 20
minutes, even as it grows,
because of the very strong
updraft speed.
So it'll continue to grow until
it finally gets too big,
and then it'll finally
fall out.
But by that time, it may be
quite a chunk of ice that has
grown by riming.
And then as that falls to Earth,
it picks up a lot of
speed, and that could cause
damage to crops,
buildings, or people.
There will be usually hundreds
if not thousands of lightning
strikes from these severe
thunderstorms, and that's a
real danger.
And so these are big lightning
producers.
Your book describes how
lightning is produced.
It has to do with ice crystals
bouncing into each other and
then being carried off by
different vertical motions.
When they strike into each
other, they separate charge.
And electrical charges of
one sign get carried up,
developing a big voltage
difference between the upper
part of the cloud and
the lower, or the
cloud and the ground.
And then you get-- when that
breaks down, you'll get
lightning strikes.
Tornadic winds.
Tornadoes are formed by severe
thunderstorms. This is a very
important aspect of them.
Unfortunately, one of the
least well understood.
There have been a number of
recent field projects, one
just summer of 2010, in which,
once again, we mobilized
dozens of radars on mobile
trucks and all kinds of
sophisticated instruments to
try to measure tornadoes at
the moment of generation.
It's so difficult to do, because
they're random, and
they're hard to predict.
So how do you get the trucks
and the people and the
instruments together right at
the point where that tornado
is going to form?
We're working very
hard at that.
And the literature on
this is fascinating.
People are being so clever about
developing new ways to
do these measurements.
And yet today, we don't quite
understand how tornadoes form.
We do understand this, however,
that these large,
severe thunderstorms generate
a slow rotation within them.
That's called the mesocyclone
or the mesovortex.
We understand how that
forms, but that's a
slow, large-scale vortex.
It might be 40 or 50 kilometers
across and with
wind speeds of only 4 or
5 meters per second.
That certainly isn't the tornado
itself, but it may be
that somehow that rotation
gets amplified near the
surface of the Earth in certain
spots that would
generate tornadoes.
So it may be the mesovortex is
the precursor of the tornado
itself, but that's one of the
things we've been unable to
determine with scientific
certainty.
So this is a very open question,
and I'm not going to
say much more about it.
But if you want to dig in or
read about this, there's a lot
going on in research meteorology
today to try to
understand that question.
Now, here's another issue that
I'm going to mention
and then drop it.
Because there is-- speaking of
toilet bowl mythology, there
is a little bit of
mythology here.
Some people will say if a
tornado is approaching your
house, you should open
the windows.
And the reason for that is that
there's low pressure in
the center of a tornado.
We know that's true.
And if this low-pressure center
suddenly moves over
your house, you've still got
high pressure inside your
house, low pressure around it,
and your house will explode.
And the way to prevent that,
of course, is to open the
windows so that pressure can
equalize more rapidly.
Well, that little bit of advice
has been around for
many, many years.
But I know that the recent
recommendation from the
National Weather Service is
that that probably is not
valid, or at least it's not--
probably, by opening the
windows, the chances are
you'll do more damage to
your house than by
keeping them closed.
Either the wind will come in
or rain will come in and
you'll get damage that way.
There's no real strong evidence
that this pressure
difference has an effect on
exploding your house.
So I'm not going to say anything
categorical about
this except that, generally,
this is not considered to be
part of the story.
But I will say this one.
The gust front winds, so that
cool air that's generated by
evaporation below cloud base,
will fall to the surface of
the Earth and then spread out
at speeds that can almost
approach the speed of
the tornadic winds.
So the first thing that a
meteorologist will do when
there's been a severe
thunderstorm and damage has
been reported, he'll get in
his car or he'll get in a
helicopter and he'll scout the
area and try to figure out was
the damage due to the gust
front winds or from the
tornadic winds?
That's question number
one whenever these
kind of storms occur.
Can you separate the damage
caused by that cool downburst
of air from the damage caused
by the tornado itself?
We're out of time, but
we'll continue in
this theme on Wednesday.